ce camion évoqué d'abord et avant tout
l'aventuré et c'était un truc assez
sympa de dire voilà on va vous parler de
science et on va vous emmener à l'
aventure
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on ne prendrait pas un
camion américain souvenez-vous du
générique on voit le pot d'échappement
la soupape du pot d'échappement qui se
soulèvent avec un nuage de gaz
on est en 1994 je travaille avec fred
frédéric courant on travaille sur un
magazine de science mais qui a un format
plutôt classique et on commença à
cogiter à se dire ah tiens si on avait
la possibilité de faire notre émission
idéal comment comment la verrions nous
on en parlait souvent soir quand on
quand on est on allé au resto dîné
ensemble je me souviens j'ai gardé moi
d'aider des morceaux de deux nappes sur
lesquels on avait échafaudé le concept
de l'émission est donc on a présenté le
projet c'est pas mal et tout mais
c'est pas at-elle - tels qu'ils vont
représenter c'est vous et pourquoi vous
en parlait très bien vous vous
maîtrisiez le sujet manifestement alors
banco c'est parti la première émission
de c'est pas sorcier sur les volcans
nous sommes allés en sicile sur l'etna
et on a eu la chance d'assister au
réveil de l'etna ont été positionnés à
500 mètres du cratère et on a passé la
nuit à observer cette interruption il
faut imaginer qu'on était à 500 mètres
du cratère que le cratère lui même
faisait 500 mètres de hauteur et au
moment de ce qu'on appelle le paroxysme
de l'éruption sert le moment où le g2
l'avs et le plus puissant et bien il
faisait lui aussi 500 mètres de hauteur
et ça ça a duré de minuit à 5 heures du
matin et c'est un truc extraordinaire
j'avais demandé à l'ingénieur du son
avec qui j'étais sûr sur l'etna de à
l'époque c'étaient des délais des voix
la donne faire un dvd du duduk du son du
volcan quand mes enfants étaient petits
et qu'ils étaient un peu trop turbulent
est bien faisait un temps calme et je
mettais le disque
le cd est là on avait un espèce de
ça calme et tout le monde attendait à
lui dire quelque chose qu'il a mal
digéré première fois que j'ai expliqué
comment fonctionnait une aile d'avion
avec une aile fabriqué en carton et puis
un sèche-cheveux l'est les montées sur
deux deux fils transparent et je
j'oriente le sèche-cheveux et je voi
elle qui monte tout seul voilà c'est
bien ça parle tout seul mais en même
temps il ya aussi eu des moments plus
difficiles on avait fait une fois une
émission sur l'air donc faisons une
émission sur l'air ayant de l'air à
disposition autour de nous on s'était
dit qu'on allait faire beaucoup
d'expérience avec ce qu'on avait autour
de nous le maquettiste avait testé
toutes les maquettes dans son atelier
dans lequel il n'y avait pas de
chauffage et dans son atelier et faisait
aux alentours de 13 14 degrés sur le
plateau il fait beaucoup plus chaud fait
plutôt 30 degrés sauf que l'air un
comportement totalement différent à 30
degrés quelque 14 degrés et tout ce que
nous avions prévu
rien ne fonctionnait il a fallu tout
refaire tout revoir les calculs les
distances et serra et ces gens c'est une
émission de 1 à 2 heures du matin on est
donc encore en train de tourner alors
qu'habituellement on finissait aux
alentours de 18 heures